hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast navigating the immunological
micro environment inside you to uncover
the hidden clues of cancer immunology
I'm Judy O'Rourke on levers and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labyrinth comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
the company helps scientists clinicians
and lab professionals accelerate their
science through its innovative detection
imaging services and informatics
solutions PerkinElmer is knowledge base
and expertise supports the discovery of
critical insights in Diagnostics life
sciences and environmental applications
and helps connect human and
environmental health for more
information please visit
www.lifebliss.org/events.asp our welcome
to and you can do this by hitting the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we'll try to
get to as many as we can and we'll
follow up if we don't have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome
Edward stack PhD pathology application
scientists at PerkinElmer doctor stat
carried out postdoctoral research at
Boston University where he began to
develop his interest in human
translational research is carried out
many oncology studies examining disease
mechanisms in multiple cancer types
while at the Dana Farber Cancer
Institute he served as the associate
director of the Dana Farber Brigham and
Women's Center for molecular oncological
pathologist rector in the pathology
department of Brigham
women and the Harvard Medical School dr.
Steph was also a member of the
dana-farber Harper word cancer center in
both the gastrointestinal malignancies
and prostate cancer research program as
a pathology scientist at PerkinElmer
give me dr. stack is developing cancer
immunology focused tissue based assays
which can provide deeper insights and to
cancer host interactions and assist in
clinical management of cancer I will now
turn the presentation over to dr. stack
hi everybody and thanks for joining us
today I'd like to start by sort of
offering a perspective relative to
immunotherapies where currently we see
with checkpoint inhibition significant
durable effects leading to lasting
durable responses in many cancer types
and this is contrasted with early
genomic identification providing a
window into small molecule inhibitors
which provides a media benefit but never
the real durable response some of the
very exciting and tantalizing clinical
trial data that is currently available
demonstrates that in very aggressive
forms of disease such as metastatic
bladder cancer or refractory Hodgkin's
lymphoma the administration of drugs
targeting checkpoint pathways unleashing
immune system activity in cancer result
in the case of metastatic bladder cancer
55 percent of patients who engage in a
two-year progression free survival while
in the case of Hodgkin's lymphoma 87
percent of patients will engage in
progression-free survival one of the
challenges however to leveraging these
checkpoint inhibitor blockade drugs is
that understanding where we can do so
and how that will leverage a response in
any disease is entirely unpredictable
for example we know that roughly 45
percent of patients in a whole host of
cancer types will respond
positively the pd-1 or PDL one
checkpoint blockade the complication
resides in the fact that there are
patients who will demonstrate PDL one
immuno reactivity yet will not
demonstrate a response to PD one axis
blockade and then conversely there are
indeed patients who do not show PDL one
immuno activity but do show responses to
PD one access blockade and the reason
for this is fairly simple in that the
immune system and the micro environment
is fairly complex
for example we already know that there
are a number of immune cell types which
when found in the tumor are associated
with favourable outcomes yet there are a
significant and alternate number of
immune phenotypes which when found in
the tumor are associated with adverse
outcomes and this is primarily because
the tumor microenvironment
is a complicated space there are
elements of the micro environment which
are part of the tumor and its associated
non immunological landscapes such as the
endothelial compartments in the chronic
area is you have fat you have parasites
and athili 'm and you also have cancer
associated fibroblasts all of these
exist potentially alongside a whole host
of potential immune markers or cell
types such as dendritic cells or a
number of T cells B cells various
numbers of myeloid and macrophage cells
and natural killer cells and all of
these are in fact interacting with the
tumor but it's also likely that there is
interactions among themselves all of
which sets up how the immune system
potentially interacts with cancer to
unlock the complexities of the immune
system in cancer we certainly need new
methodologies that help us to visualize
multiple tissue biomarkers and
importantly we need to preserve context
and this is what PerkinElmer spin'
optics application can do phenomics
consists of a multiplex staining
paradigm
coupled to a multispectral imaging
modality and leveraged via an image
analysis platform to guide a much deeper
understanding of the tumor
microenvironment our multicolored
multiplex IHC paradigm is based on
fluorescence in part because
fluorophores often have a much better
dynamic range than their chroma genetic
counterparts which means that we have
better control over quantitation and
spectral separation importantly when we
leverage multispectral imaging we are
very capable in unmixing up to 4
co-localize signals where when chroma
genic multiplexing is attempted it's
very unlikely to get anything beyond 2
in any specific cellular compartment
there are many challenges however
associated with multiplexing there are
antibodies species interferences which
usually sort of prevent standard well
optimized anti rabid or anti Mouse
primary approaches from you know
reactivity to be leveraged in a
multiplex
assay if that can be accomplished there
are then weak or imbalanced signals
associated with lowly expressed versus
highly expressed antigens
there's photo bleaching which quenches
four fours and often precludes any
archival capacity whatsoever and then
finally there is auto fluorescence and
autofluorescence in particular relative
to FFP tends to mask markers that are in
the blue end of the spectrum and all of
these issues make multiplexing in FFP
difficult but PerkinElmer has developed
a solution which we call opal our opal
multiplexing is based on pyramide signal
amplification and it supports
multiplexing of any validated primary
regardless of species this can often
improve sensitivity by 10 to 100 fold
reducing antibody consumption and
providing excellent resolution to
background the way in
pyramide works through covalent
modification of proteins and amino acids
adjacent to the epitope directed by any
primary complex allows for increasing
multiplexing through multiple biomarker
detection it works essentially like this
we can take four rabbit monoclonal
antibodies and we can infective ly
interrogate the presence of cd20 cd8 cd4
and PDL one by taking advantage of the
fact that antibody interactions with
epitopes are non covalent in nature
which means they are fairly labile when
we use these antibodies to guide the
deposition of any specific target we can
effectively label the protein with the
target but because we've removed the
primary we are now in a great position
to repeat in an iterative process the
application of another primary using a
different colored four or four by the
time we finish this process what we have
essentially engendered is a multiplex
reaction where we label the proteins
that we're interested in with four
Chrome's that we can see this reaction
is actually very specific here we have a
human melanoma cell line and this is a
cell line interrogated for the presence
of GM 130 which is a marker for the
cysts face of the golgi sister neck the
presence of GM 130 as indicated on this
photo electron micrograph at the arrow
in the centre of the image showing a
band of discrete puncta which
demonstrates the presence of GM 130 this
assay can be reconfigured such that
instead of using a secondary nano gold
for detection we can insert and the
investigators here did and a secondary
HRP antibody which will direct the
deposition of a PSA molecule attached to
biotin and the biotin can then be
interrogated through streptavidin nano
gold to reveal a
staining pattern which is seen here one
of the interesting things about this
pattern is that while the relative
detection of GM 130 is amplified through
the introduction of pyramide signal
amplification the thing to note is the
relative spatial separation that is
observed between all of the specific
areas where GM 130 positivity is
observed this suggests s' a very
specific specificity of deposition
guided through proper titration of the t
si si when we do this using opal we can
actually stain a human tonsil with an
antibody directed against cd8 which
happens to be a Dean tex clone of c8 144
be the image you see before you shows
immune reactivity primarily within the
follicular mantle of the tonsil with the
area to the left of the image
demonstrating a paucity within the
germinal Center in this context we can
develop this image and we can heat this
sample to remove the gene text anti cd8
primary and we can follow with a DA Co
cd8 primary again of clone c8 144 B when
we look at the combined signal we see
that the vast majority of cd8 are
positive for both the gene text and the
taco primary and this tells us that when
the first gene text primary is laid down
the available binding sites for tsa are
never saturated such that when the
subsequent anti cd8 from Dhaka lay down
there are still available binding sites
so we control very specifically through
titration the deposition of T sa the
opal signal is also very fidelity and
this is something that will be important
if one runs a multiplex because one has
to be certain the information obtained
in the multiplex is absolutely the same
as what could be achieved in
single plex context so the two images
you see before you are serial breast
cancer samples the image on the right
shows the her2 immunofluorescence and
the Dappy counter stain the image on the
left also shows you the her2 signal as
well as the deputy under stain but what
you do not see is that this sample is
also stained for the estrogen receptor
the progesterone receptor ki-67 and
cytokeratin and the interesting thing is
is that when you measure the overall her
two signal from the multiplex and
compare it to the single plex and do
this for a number of cases the relative
concordance is greater than 0.9 showing
that the information we achieve and
multiplex is very specific and identical
to that in which a single Plex detection
can be achieved here we have some basic
examples of the kinds of multiplexing we
can achieve here you have a human breast
cancer this is stained with cd4 cd8 cd20
and cytokeratin the cytokeratin is the
cyan and you can note where the tumor is
here while the vast number of cd4
eight-and-twenty which are the green the
purple and the red cells respectively
occupy the stromal confines of the tumor
with very little tumor infiltration here
is an example of one of the most
aggressive multiplexes that we can
engender this is a lung cancer stained
with cd4 cd8 cd68 from macrophages Fox
p3 for regulatory T cells as well as PDL
1 and cytokeratin and you can see the
ability to create these fantastically
multicolored images but this leaves us
with a particular requirement and that
is we must be able to analyze these
multicolored samples for the analysis of
multicolored samples we leverage
multispectral imaging for a very simple
reason colors that we can see are not as
discreet as the underlying spectra which
constitute those colors and there's an
added advantage
using a multispectral system and that is
autofluorescence within FFP also has a
very describable spectra so in the sense
of EGFR expression in breast cancer for
example one could use a conventional
monochrome bandpass acquisition for EGFR
on a floor scene died we know that EGFR
expression is meant to be restricted to
cell membranes so we measure the
expression at all of the cell membranes
but because we need to take account of
the background we will measure say the
nucleus where we know we should see no
EGFR expression yet because of the
significant autofluorescence
contamination you see in this image the
signal to background ratio is actually
quite poor however in a multi spectral
context if you take an unstained tissue
section and measure its Auto
fluorescence spectra you can apply that
spectra coincident with the detection of
fluorescein thus when you measure EGFR
at the membrane you are measuring solely
the fluorescein signal minus the auto
fluorescent contribution so now when you
actually take account of the background
you can see we have a much more improved
signal to background ratio which helps
us once we have these images unmixed we
have great quantitative potential the
systems which can accomplish this or the
PerkinElmer Vectra and PerkinElmer
mantra systems these systems can
accommodate both fluorescence and bright
field as well as multi spectral imaging
they can easily perform this on tissue
microarrays and whole tissue sections
the advantage is that Vectra also
possesses is it retains an access
controlled stage which allows us to take
10x whole slide images of any slide that
we have and this supports any number of
strategies to be directed toward ROI
assessment from manual selection based
on morphological criteria through
leveraging algorithms that can find
specific morphologies
and find any number of fields that have
X percentage of such morphology or even
applying a standard stereo logical
approach where X number of fields can be
found in a stereo logical context the
advantage is is that once an ROI is
selected through any of the modalities
I've described the information is fed
back to vectra's so that it will
effectively acquire a 20x
ms:i field which can then be leveraged
in our image analysis software which we
call inform this can help us to advance
any phenotypic analysis we can leverage
the spectral libraries that we have and
thus we can apply those spectral
libraries so we can take a raw
florescent image and we can provide its
underlying spectral composite from this
perspective it is possible to leverage a
number of algorithms inherent in the
in-form software that allow us to a
identify specific morphological features
relative to tissue so we can apply
tissue segmenting rules be using
counterstain based approaches find every
single cell in this particular image and
see with the requirement of cell
segmentation being satisfied I can
define any phenotype I think I can
recognize in this image and I can train
the software to find those phenotypes so
by defining say in this image of breast
cancer showing the system what I know to
be tumor versus what I know to be stroma
we can effectively segment tumor from
stroma using the Dappy counterstain I
can find every single cell that exists
in this image by defining certain
phenotypes based on the stain I have in
this image which includes cd4 cd8 cd20
and Fox p3 I can define helper T cells
cytotoxic T cells B cells regulatory T
cells and PDL one positive cells and I
can create this phenotype map which
shows the relative location of all of
these cell types in a very discreet
Cartesian
in coordinate system where a Cartesian
plane is reliably maintained once the
data is collected inform assembles the
data in a text tab delimited fashion
which means this data can be driven into
any analytical software package one
chooses from Excel to Spotfire to SS
SPSS to flo-jo even as well as being
quite amenable for any type of are
related interrogation so with that in
mind what I'd like to be able to do now
is just show you how our approach allows
for different phenotypes to be
visualized and quantified simultaneously
in the same tissue section helping to
enable the study of relationships and
the distribution of cells within any
tumor and its associated micro
environment and to do this I'd like to
share with you a couple of case studies
the first involves a study of head and
neck squamous cell carcinoma here you
see a head and neck squamous cell
carcinoma and this is an image stained
with cd8 cd4 Fox p3 PDL 1 and sox10 4 to
identify the tumor the interest here is
specifically at the border between the
tumor which occupies the upper left hand
side of the image versus the stroma
which occupies a much smaller lower
right hand side of the image we are able
to effectively draw a boundary that
extends roughly 200 microns into the
tumor as well as 200 microns into the
stroma because what we're interested in
assessing is the interaction that's
occurring at this space so when we
actually draw the border essentially
providing direction to the software of
where we want to
two segments we can provide our spectral
library which allows us to find the
regulatory t-cells through Fox p3 the
the endothelial cells through cd34 the
PDL one positive cells through PL 1 and
this cd8 through to identify cytotoxic
t-cells ad this specific Junction and
this is the kind of map that you have so
it's very clear you can segment to find
vessels based on cd34 you can find tumor
based on socket n and you can find
stronger based on the lack of sox10 we
were interested to look at the relative
relationship between cell types and you
can take the informed data you can run
specific spatial point patterning
assessments such as nearest neighbor
assessments and in this instance you can
see our ability a to phenotype but then
relate the specific distances of certain
phenotypes in this case the relative
relationship from any cd8 to the nearest
PDL one positive cell and you can do
this both in the tumor and the stroma
here you see the relative relationships
between cd8 to the nearest regulatory
t-cell part of the advantage of running
any multi spectral analysis is the fact
that we have great control over the
quantitative capacity existing in the
assay so for example when one sets up an
H score for PDL one it's a very accurate
H score and here you can see when we
measure PDL one expression we see two
different cases where we see wildly
divergent H score suggesting significant
differences in PDL one expression but we
also have relative density and distance
measurements so we know for instance how
to calculate the average number of PDL
one positive cells within ten or twenty
five microns of t regs as well as doing
a similar analysis except now we measure
the relative cytotoxic t cells that
exist within those specific barriers and
you can see here that when you can
accurately
these densities you can begin to see
differences that can emerge between
various samples the amount of data that
exists in any multiplex assay allows us
to say a great many things about n
individual samples so we can begin to
build a very significant compendium of
measurements that help us to more
accurately understand the biology of
tumors and begin to consider how we
might better build biomarkers to help us
understand the trajectory of disease
with this in mind I'd like to share with
you a study recently published showing
the relative expression of ox40 PDO 1
and ctla-4 in tumor infiltrating T cells
from head and neck squamous cell cancer
because squamous cell cancers can be
associated with HPV the cohort consisted
of both HPV positive as well as HPV
negative cases and looking at the
relative age of cases there was no
difference relative to HPV status when
box 40 is this is assessed via flow one
of the things that they can see is that
if you look at t reg expression here you
can see that if you look at the t regs
from the tumor versus two regs
identified within peripheral blood the
relative percentage of T regs is much
higher in the tumor compared to those in
circulation while the you have a similar
significance of seeing more conventional
cd4s and cd8 in tumor as opposed to
peripheral blood the magnitude of the
shift in ox40 expression in the t read
compartment is quite robust this is in
contrast with what we see in terms of
PDL one here you see that by flow PDL
one expression is high on both T regs on
cd4s as well as CD
eight showing that pd-1 expression
exists in all of these phenotypes to a
similar degree yet it is more profound
in the tumor relative to the peripheral
blood interestingly if one looks at
ctla-4 one sees that there are a
significant proportion of regulatory T
cells which are ctla-4 found both in
peripheral blood as well as in tumor
while you still see the significant
shifts in tumor for both the CTL a
positive cd4s and cd8 through flow if
the gate is set on ox40
the goal was for the study to select the
PDL 1 positive CTL a positive cells
triple positive cells were common in cd4
cells roughly 7 and a half percent of
cd4 cells were triple positive it was
relatively rare in the cd8 where only
0.7% of the cd8 were triple positive
however the T regs had the most triple
positive cells in this case nearly 45
percent of T regs isolated from tumor
showed a triple positivity of ox40 PD 1
and ctla-4 the reason I'm sharing all
this with you is because the authors
also looked at a multi spectral
multiplex approach and what they found
was that ox40 T cells were found mainly
in the tumor while PDL 1 positive T
cells were found both in the stroma and
tumor here the PD 1 cells are red while
the ox40 are yellow the Fox p3 are green
then the cd3 are magenta while Dappy is
the back stained blue the yellow arrow
indicates a specific ox40 cd3 Fox p3
positive cell while the red arrow
indicates an ox for T CD 3 positive Fox
p3 negative the magenta arrow shows an
ox for T CD 3 positive ox40 negative
rather CD 3 positive Fox p3 positive
regulatory cell while the white arrow
show
ox40 cd3 positive PDL one positive cell
the inset points to cells Co expressing
both ox40 and PDL one interestingly the
brightest ox40 expressed also expressed
Fox p3 which is very consistent with the
flow analyses also observed the majority
of PDA one positive P cells were ox40
negative and so the take-home here is we
have a great ability to understand the
expression of multiple immune checkpoint
accesses operating within head and neck
squamous cell carcinoma and this might
help to guide more effective
combinatorial treatment strategies
through flow cytometry the authors
demonstrated lymphocytes isolated from
tumors show elevated ox40 expression
compared to circulating lymphocytes and
this was primarily on Fox p3 positive T
regs while both PDL 1 and ctla-4
expression was elevated in all cell
types regulatory t-cells helper T cells
and cytotoxic T cells concordant tissue
analyses demonstrated that the ox40
cells were found mainly in tumor while
pd 1 positive cells were found both in -
in stroma and this is very consistent
with the flow cytometry assessment which
showed the brightest ox40 expression Co
Express with Fox p3 so here you have
where a multiplex assay can recapitulate
but flow sees but also provide context
which flow would potentially lack so
shifting gears a little bit I would like
to share with you a different
perspective relative to an assessment of
melanoma up sorry I went backwards so
here we have a human melanoma this is
actually staying with PDL one cd8 Fox p3
cd20 socket n and CD 163 serving as a
marker for macrophages using Dappy as a
counter stain interestingly one of the
things that multispectral imaging allows
you to do is work backward from a
spectral composite to create simulated H
and E's where spectral composites lack
some context through lack of counter
stain or morphology when
we work backwards to create these
simulated hmes we have much greater
contextual understanding of what we see
so now it's it's quite clear you can see
where certain lymphocytes are relative
to certain tumor cells importantly we
can demonstrate all of the stains we
have performed fluorescently as
chromogenic stains which gives context
back to a pathology view helping us to
more appropriately understand the
relative staining patterns but
importantly buried in the spectral
composite data is a very robust capacity
to perform pattern recognition so we can
find tumor versus stroma we can then
perform a very discreet PD l18 score by
setting thresholds for 0 to 3 binning
and and precisely quantitating the
number of positive cells in each bin and
we can also do this for positivity
thresholds so we know exactly how many
regulatory t-cells we have through Fox
p3 positivity threshold vs. cd8 defined
defining the cytotoxic T component if we
come back to our rather contextually
naive melanoma one of the things we can
do is we can segment this melanoma so we
can define tumor and we can define
stroma and we'll also identify where no
tissue exists and then we can perform
phenotyping analysis so I can find all
of the socks 10 positive PDA one
positive cells as well as all the socks
10 positive PDL or negative cells I can
find all the regulatory t-cells through
Fox p3 the cytotoxic T cells or cd8 the
the B cells through cd20 and the
macrophages through C D 163 and when I
do that I can engender this very
complicated map of both tumor areas
stroma area and specific cell phenotype
one of the interesting things that we
can engender from the data output from
this is where our cells actually
interacting between men
brain that could be actually very
important if one wants to understand how
for instance a tumor may be modifying an
immune response to avoid immune
detection and engage in immune escape so
it might be very interesting to look at
how the cd8 cells are oriented to the PD
alone positive tumor cells and by
leveraging specific analyses in R we can
manipulate those the informed data such
that we can show you specific maps that
identify the interactions which occur
from both the perspective of either the
PDL and positive tumor cells or the
cytotoxic T cells so you can get a very
discreet understanding of the relative
cellular interactions which are
occurring within the confines of a
specific image here you see an
alternative view looking at the relative
relationship between cd8 positive cells
relative to macrophages and from an
immunological perspective this may be a
very relevant assay in that macrophages
retain both MHC 1 and MHC 2 capacity so
they're in a very good position to
communicate not only with cd8 s but also
cd4s
and thus drive specific
micro-environment responses so you have
great control over the ability to
perform any number of spatial point
pattern assessments but to show you how
this assay can actually be leveraged in
the context of melanoma research here we
have a study published by the Fox group
out of Providence Cancer Center in
Portland Oregon looking at multispectral
imaging to predict the ability to
generate tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
from melanoma samples in the treatment
of melanoma it is often the case that
melanoma samples will be removed and
digested either through mechanical or
enzymatic digestion in an attempt to
isolate till and expand the till
population and look for specific
interferon gamma producing T cells
because that can be used in an adoptive
t-cell transfer protocol where those
interferon gamma producing T cells can
be injected back into patients to help
manage melanoma what you can see in this
graph is that the authors
show the relative inability to know a
priori which melanomas will give rise to
effective till or not and this
represents a particular problem so the
authors looked to a multiplex assay to
help them address whether they could
predict which melanomas would give rise
to effective interferon gamma producing
till here you have two images where till
generation was not possible versus where
it was if you look at the relative
density of either CD 3 or CD 8 based on
your ability to assess this in the
multiplex one of the things you can see
is that neither of those density
measurements provide any predictive
capacity for which melanomas give rise
to effective interferon gamma producing
t-cells
however if one looks at the relative
ratio of cd8 to Fox p3 the predictive
capacity of this multiplex rises to 92%
and when this is coupled with the ratio
of cd8 to PDL 1 the predictive capacity
here rises to 100% so here we know we
can gain a greater understanding of the
ways in which cells are arranged within
this complicated and contextual micro
environment and this helps us to better
understand the mechanisms of disease but
since the generation of autologous till
populations to be used for adoptive
t-cell therapy is challenging the use of
a multiplex assay can help to positively
impact the view regarding potential for
a CT and this can ensure higher degrees
of a CT till driven expansion success
and this can potentially serve as a
useful biomarker for achieving such and
so I think you can see through these
cases how we can achieve very specific
understandings of both biology but begin
to help build better biomarkers and with
this in mind I would like to share one
final example of a study recently
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine
looking at Pemberley zoom AB pd-1
blockade in advanced Merkel cell
carcinoma and here we have the relative
response characteristics panel a shows
the maximum percent change from baseline
in the some of the longest diameters of
the target lesions in 24 patients who
underwent radiologic evaluation after
treatment panel B shows the kinetics of
the change in target lesion diameters
over time during Pemberley zoom ab there
appear I'll see shows the
characteristics of 16 patients who
initially had evidence of response
according to resist criteria and what
you see in the survival plot is
progression-free survival which was
measured from treatment initiation to
disease progression or death which ever
occurred first and what this study
showed was that 55% of patients who were
treated with Pember lism ab showed one
year of progression-free survival the
study attempted to try and drive
biomarker development by looking at pre
and post-treatment biopsies and
assessing cytokeratin for presence or
absence of the Merkel cell tumor cm to
b4 which also looks at polyomavirus
Merkel cell carcinomas are highly
comorbid with polyomavirus and also
looking at cd8 and so here you can see
the primary Merkel cell carcinoma and
the post treatment biopsy the inset
shows you in the primary mcc significant
tumor and stroma interactions while in
the post treatment biopsy you see no
evidence of tumor and this is supported
by the paucity of cytokeratin and C - cm
- before with a significant upregulation
of cd8 however when the authors
attempted to define response based on
either cd8 or viral load based on cd8
neither till status or viral load
correlated with response
so here you have biomarkers which are
not providing specific at information
relative to response to preamble ISM app
interestingly the authors also included
this multi flexed multi spectral figure
which demonstrates an analysis of the
archival biopsy specimen showing an
immune infiltrate that is most intense
at the tumor stroma interface in the
panel on the left the Green is showing
the relative PDL one immune reactivity
this particular immune reactivity is at
the border of the Merkel cell cancer and
there are many tumors which are PDA one
positive those are indicated by blue
arrows but there are also specific
macrophages which are also PDL and
positive which are identified by the red
arrows these the cd8 positive T cells
are the yellow cells you can see them
quite clearly in the stroma
interestingly when they get closer to
and begin to interact with the tumor
they are also pd-1 positive and that is
shown by double positive cells which are
indicated as white and the thing I think
was most intriguing about this study was
the way in which the authors positioned
this their statements indicated ongoing
studies which would correlate features
of the tumor microenvironment with
clinical outcome of checkpoint blockades
such as examining the expression of
additionally checkpoints the composition
density and geography of T cell
infiltrates using the multiplex analyses
are anticipated to reveal more specific
and powerful predictors because right
now there is no predictive test which is
robust enough to be used in determining
whether or not to use PD one blockers
not only in Merkel cell carcinoma but I
would submit in many add no carcinomas
so there is clearly a need to develop
better biomarker strategies and here you
see where the authors of this Merkel
cell carcinoma trial
are pointing to multiplex assays because
they believe this may be the key to
unlock a microenvironment and help them
build better biomarkers so in conclusion
I would like to summarize that
PerkinElmer is driven to improve
quantitative multiplex IHC and with
these methods we believe we can improve
translational pathology research to
uncover spatial patterns that help us to
more specifically understand not only
tumour mean ology but the way in which
the tumor microenvironment is organized
certainly through the use of open
multiplex staining we offer a simplified
multiplex assay that can help speed the
understanding of cancer immunology and
advance biomarker development and when
used in conjunction with multi spectral
imaging and inform analysis we can
arrive at very discrete quantitative
potential certainly when these methods
are applied to cancer immunology we can
open up contextual windows and these can
synergize with highly multiplex yet
contextually naive methods such as deep
sequencing or flow cytometry and this
can build a much greater understanding
of of a specific disease process in the
hopes of building better biomarkers I
would like to finish simply by letting
everyone know that PerkinElmer provides
reagents that allow any antibody to be
folded into a four color five color six
color or seven color assay PerkinElmer
also provides complete kits which
include buffers primary and secondary
antibodies as well as opal detection
reagents these kids can accommodate the
detection of cd4 cd8 and cd20 in a four
color assay and there are specific seven
color assays which we leverage in multi
spectral context that can find cd4 cd8
cd20 Fox p3 and cytokeratin and they
will shift between either cd68 from
macrophage or cd45 r o for specific
memory t-cells and then finally there is
a specific kit that includes cd4 cd8 and
cd68 detection capacity but also offers
three open channels so that
investigators can fold in
any antibody of choice PerkinElmer
provides both the vector ahead mantra
multispectral imaging systems as well as
the associated inform image analysis
system and lastly PerkinElmer provides
multiplex painting and multispectral
imaging as a service so I would like to
acknowledge many of the people
responsible for much of what you've seen
in this presentation specifically our
applications group consisting of cliff
Hoyt Christian Roman and Qigong Liang as
well as our R&D group consisting of Yu
Jiang Lobby foods and like pisano as
well various collaborators at Providence
Cancer Center including doctors Fox and
zip Fang dr. Talbot Johns Hopkins and
doctors Paul nyam and Candice Church at
Fred Hodge Cancer Research Center with
this I would like to say thanks and
certainly if there are any questions in
the remaining time that we have I'd be
very happy to answer them and I again
want to thank everybody for for your
attention excellent presentation dr.
stack thanks for bringing that
information to us but before we get
started with all your questions use a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we'll take
as many as we can our first question
comes from Shara and she asked connector
ado whole slide streaming and how the
stitching work
so the could you repeat the question
because I thought I heard a whole slide
staining and I just wanted to make sure
I understood properly I can Vectra do
whole slide imaging yes so vector3 can
conduct non multi spectral fluorescent
based whole slide imaging so we can
image any slide be it a whole tissue
section or a tissue microarray
leveraging the spectral the fluorescent
epic you bet are in the system these
include the data cube the 50 Q the sy 3
cube the Texas red cube and the sy 5
cube and this engenders a fluorescent
multiplex whole slide image which can
used for specific ROI selection the the
stitching is performed via the software
so vector3 assembles what's known as a
QP TIFF which is a completely stitched
image through the use of the access
controlled stage every 10x image is then
joined together to provide that whole
slide image which can then be viewed in
a number of software programs we use
Fino chart for our assessment phenotype
works with vector ax to help not only
select the ROI but feed that information
back into vector ax to guide MSI but
there are other third-party software's
such as halo which can also be that that
QP TIFF and perform halo related NLCS as
well soo-jung asks why does it seem the
later staining guys have more background
than the earlier standing dice and how
can we deal with this issue well that's
an interesting question and I think that
when the assays are tighter drop early
so our single slide controls define
protocol requirements that can be then
leveraged in the multi-plex protocol it
should be that the signal you see in
your single Plex
should be exactly the same as you see in
your multiplex so if you are seeing
background in the multiplex there is
probably a few reasons why that could be
the case it may be that with successive
rounds of antigen retrieval there is
more efficient exposure of an epitope
which means you would have more primary
present that would lead to more HRP
presence in the in the sample through
more primary being detected and if the
HRP to opal ratio goes out of whack a
little bit you can get what's known as
dimer formation where instead of
directing opal dyes down to the epitope
they actually find each other first and
they can settle creating backgrounds so
if background is the case one might want
to look at the relative intensity of
that signal
because if the intensity is very very
high it's likely that you're getting
more HRP than you intend in the system
and that's what could be producing
background Alice masks are the imaging
instruments based on multiphoton imaging
more like confocal and could they be
used for second harmonic generation so
certainly in the case of the opal dyes
any spectral system including spectral
confocal systems can be used to
essentially drive detection in terms of
harmonics I'm not entirely sure given
the nature by which the opal signal is
deposited that harmonics could be as
effective there and there's also the
added complication of most spectral
confocal systems do not have the ability
to assess any specific spectra from 400
to roughly 700 nanometers so relative to
the assessment part of autofluorescence
the confocal systems would not have as
significant and ability to reduce
autofluorescence as our multi spectral
systems which are based on light
microscopy but clearly multi spectral
confocal can accurately separate and
define specific opal die so you could
leverage to a certain degree that
capacity but I will say that what we
achieve relative to our image analysis
and the simplicity by which we can
arrive at image analysis for downstream
data processing and assessment I think
we can achieve in a far greater and more
timely fashion than what could be
achieved through perhaps a slightly more
complicated spectral confocal paradigm
by all three asks you mentioned up to
four Co localized markers were unmixed
in fluorescence modality where all the
markers on the same cellular compartment
and if so
which cellular compartment sure so
there's some data that's been presented
at the use cat meetings in Boston about
two years ago and then again at the Ash
meeting where Chris caret excuse me
where Chris Terry and colleagues they
looked at macrophage behavior in the
context of Hodgkin's lymphoma and they
were very capable to to identify
macrophages which were cd68 positive as
well as CT 163 positive as well as PDL
one positive all three stains being
localized to the membrane segment of m2
macrophages and the ability for the
system to be able to find those
macrophages is actually very robust in
fact you could even see in some of those
images some of the macrophages which
were also P stat 3 positive in the
nuclei so our ability to look at these
multiplex markers is actually fairly
robust and even in the context of the
head/neck data that I showed you could
easily identify ox40 positive cv 3
positive pd-1 positive t-cells within
the context of head and neck squamous
cell tumors so it's very clear that when
these assays are tired properly we're
very good at finding many of these
markers on the membrane and there is
additional data relative to pi3 kinase
which was I was I think in abstract form
at the AACR meeting perhaps a year ago
where a group demonstrated the ability
to look at pi3 kinase signaling relative
to prostate cancer and they were looking
at three cytoplasmic markers to identify
signal transduction so there are many
examples in the published literature
that show that this is the case
Carolina mentions the staining and
imaging and analysis system you have
described as impressive and can resolve
high level of complexity with a maximum
limit of eight biomarkers antibody
detection of protein markers can
sometimes be technically challenging so
she asks I was wondering how many
different antibody detection protein
markers tend to get used on average and
then she has another question can your
technique be adapted to RNA probes when
detection of specific proteins is
challenging sure so our multiplex assay
if I had to guess conservatively we have
probably looked at over 100 different
primary antibodies looking at a whole
host of immunological markers in a whole
host of different tissues so the rule of
thumb is if any antibody can provide
contextual specificity using standard
chromogenic detection then it can be
folded into a multiplex assay that being
said sometimes antigens are actually
quite difficult to detect and I will say
that B antibody we use for Fox p3 is not
rated for immunohistochemistry it is
only rated for Western blots and flow
cytometry yet given the sensitivity of
TSA we can get a very contextually
specific new clearly restricted Fox p3
signal coincident with cd4 expression so
we can get a very good Fox p3 signal
based on the sensitivity of TSA to
detect even my new amounts of detected
primary and so we have a very well
optimized protocol to fold in new
antibodies to a specific PSA based
multiplex assay but it's always
important to know that those antibodies
are contextually specific and once you
can prove that you have textual
specificity relative to the expectation
based on biological assessment for any
target in an essay those antibodies can
then be leveraged I would say in general
the majority of antibodies that we
leverage for an opal multiplex are
usually either rabbit or mouse
monoclonal primaries Eric asks what is
the maximum
number of epitopes that can be
visualized simultaneously I currently we
can our kids can support the detection
of six biomarkers in terms of epitopes
if one is indicating epitopes on a
particular protein i am not aware of any
studies that look at different epitopes
on the on a specific protein but given
the data i shared earlier where one
could interrogate cd8 using the same
clones identified by two different
manufacturers my suspicion would be that
one could take an end terminus and a c
terminus from any protein and be able to
reliably stain and resolve the specific
acid i would also like to get back to a
question i failed to mention earlier
relative to the ability to label RNA
with PSA and provided that there is a
detection strategy that employs HRP it
is quite possible to use our opal stains
for RNA detection chandra asks how much
is your assay automated and can we
couple it to like a bond Ventana
at present the assay is manual and it is
done on the bench although PerkinElmer
has and are in the effort to bring this
assay into an automated platform but we
do not have any evidence as yet as to
how well this functions in an automated
capacity we hope to have information
regarding automated staining available
sometime in the near future
Tammy asks what about the use of these
resources amounts to more models so one
of the complications in doing murine i8c
is that a lot of the markers which one
can interrogate in mice the antibodies
are not particularly good so the the
caveat is
you can run this assay wherever you get
specific detection of murine molta
immunities to chemistry and in fact
there was a recent study published in
immunology by Miss upsetting maybe about
six weeks ago they looked at the
relative fixation protocols the relative
antigen retrieval protocols in terms of
both antigen retrieval modality and pH
and they defined a specific set of
criteria that could accurately identify
cd3 cd4 cd8 and Fox p3 within sarcoma
and squamous cell carcinoma mouse models
so when you have antibodies that are
effective at providing biological
specificity ople multiplexing can be
used copy Ella asks are these reagents
suitable for Mouse tissue and frozen
tissue and do you have any experience
working with frozen tissue so the very
earliest TSA based multiplexing studies
performed by susanna Toth and FM se
showed that using frozen tissues they
could effectively multiplex tyrosine
hydroxylase vasopressin and
corticotropin-releasing hormone in in
rat brain so clearly it can be used in
frozen tissues I think I already have
indicated that yes provided you have
fidelity of an antibody to direct the
target detection of any molecule in a
mouse ople can be used but it's really
important to understand all of the
various parameters relative to fixation
and antigen retrieval so that you can
get the best detection possible Richard
asks can you please go over the steps in
the staining process sure so it's a
basic immunoassay where we will take a
tissue section we will deep era fine
eyes it and then we will rehydrate it in
graded alcohols we then will perform
antigen retrieval followed by a blocking
step where we then
apply the primary antibody and we
usually have a one-hour incubation at
room temperature we use a secondary
detection system PerkinElmer has a
secondary anti-mouse anti rabbit polymer
that polymer allows for secondary
detection over ten minutes where various
wash steps will be included to then
allow for the detection of any
particular opal dye we want to associate
with a particular target and as a
consequence we can perform that we then
perform another round of antigen
retrieval and that allows us to repeat
this process up to seven times followed
by the final round of antigen retrieval
which is then followed by application of
Gabbi for counter staining and then
cover slipping for analysis it looks
like we have time for one last question
if we didn't get to yours we will follow
up with you via email so the question is
from sherry are for those already using
in forms how can we compute the
relationship between cell types the way
showed in your presentation I would
suggest that for ship sridhara that we
find a way to communicate again and we
at PerkinElmer are very happy to
leverage our analytical capacities when
people are performing these multi-plex
multi spectral analyses using opal and
Vectra and so I'm very happy to reach
out to anybody who's interested in this
and I can help you get to that point by
leveraging what we know so you can fold
this into your lab I would like to once
again thank dr. stack for his
presentation do you have any final
comments no but I really do hope that
people found this interesting and
certainly if there are any additional
questions I please I hope you will reach
out to PerkinElmer through the email
address which was associated with this
webinar and again thanks Judy and to all
the lab roots staff for making this
possible
thank you again I would also like to
thank our sponsor PerkinElmer for making
it possible to bring this presentation
to you today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
20th
20:17 you'll receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available
on-demand and posted on lab routes calm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time